he changed the game if it wasn't for
Michael Vick all these dual threat
quarterback we never gotten an
opportunity I became a person that I
didn't really know and I was always
humble always respectful I can also say
that money changed me any time that
happens that's a recipe for disaster and
it led me down a dark road graphic
details about how Michael Vick's
Virginia property was the headquarters
of bad news kennels that dogs were
raised there to fight that Vick not only
financed the operation but took part in
gambling
and I try not to dwell on people's
thoughts in their perception because I
know I can't change I understand it I
don't blame him I do believe that
everybody's entitled to a second chance
I grew up in Newport News Virginia
you know poverty-stricken British Circle
was surrounded by a lot of you know
crime news apparently concentrated on
crack and cocaine
we had a big drug epidemic when the
drugs hit our community it just it just
kind of like destroyed we kind of lost
that sense of community and things
became so bad it became territory it got
so scary for other residents in the city
if you wait you didn't come past 25th
Street you was either Jehovah Witness or
you was an insurance man I'm hearing
gunshots every night you really don't
understand or how detrimental it is to
their environment
we had a large body of water the
Chesapeake Bay which was maybe uh five
minutes away from him from where I grew
up we used to always just go down to the
fishing pier watch other guys fish and
when I turned 11 years old for my
birthday I got a fishing boat going
fishing really helped me escape from
everything that was taking place in the
environment that I grew up in you know
it was a place of solitude it was a
sanctuary for myself it's like a safe
haven for us in a way there we was able
to stay out of trouble the older dudes
kept us from being in the streets we
have family industry you know his uncle
pops everybody they was in the street
they were trying to steer him away from
the streets planted the Boys and Girls
Club really helped me develop my skill
you know really helped me develop at the
time that I had from the age of seven
years old so we became athletes he
became a damn villain
he was in seventh grade and he was
recreation no football game I went to
see
people have been talking about this
little kid athlete got there and so
watching him he look at let ik and after
the game my winner took his hand and
said I'm coach arena and the next time
that I saw him was in eighth grade he
walked up to me he said coach I want you
to help me get where Aaron Brooks gap
then I saw him flick that risk
and I've been around that Terry
Bradshaw's the the NFL quarterbacks of
this 60 70s so I knew there was
something special I think it was just
everyday you know grind throughout all
the training camp I love camps to be had
accuracy and a footwork you know the
basics the fundamentals and I really
didn't see it it's in my junior senior
year that I was really starting to
progress as a player you know I got fast
still my arm got stronger was able to
become one of the elite in my district
he was designed to do certain things at
the quarterback position it was against
Denby Haskell and Michael went around
the right side he was supposed to thrown
the ball but he escaped he ended up
making a cut and then he cut right back
to the sideline and scored on a
touchdown I never forget after the game
my coach told me that you know that was
the NFL caliber moving when you go back
and look at it and I have to show you
the highlights a like what I saw was
remarkable agility and I said to myself
right there and I said it took him
saying you'd do that again and it'll be
on Sundays you know you hear about
different recruits that we've accrued
Mike at that time I think was rated
number two coming out of the Virginia
you know Ronald Carr was the number one
player in the country
so I heard more about Ronald Curry than
I did when I was down
visiting kids and there's a kid Ronald
Curry at the time at Hampton High School
and and Michael was at the next school
over Kerry was a heck of a player don't
get me wrong but I knew when I saw
Michael he was just there was something
different
Kevin Rogers who was mild for the
coordinators he basically told me look
this will be the next Dominick now and
keep the tradition going here at
Syracuse and when you hear something
like that obviously you want to get to
meet that you got chance to talk to him
a little bit before he showed up the kid
was hungry kid what you wanted to make a
name for itself make an impression
because he knew being in Virginia it was
about Ronald hurt we come around to the
campus we just talked about his goals a
one of the one to get done and basically
you know he told me one to cover
Syracuse and he wanted to come because I
was there and wanted to continue on that
legacy at the time his mother drove a
school bus and that was parked outside
and was not in the you know the greatest
neighborhood
when you set there and visited with them
and realize what a great mom he had and
I didn't know at the time I sitting
there or what the future was but I knew
I liked what was in that living room I
came away from there very hopeful that
this guy's gonna be at the Virginia Tech
I was excited coach was excited but he
dropped the bomb was his hey look man
you got to talk to my mom and it's like
but what's the problem she wants me to
stay home which isn't a bad choice you
know that other school in Virginia you
know the Blacksburg Virginia school a
pigmy Junior Tech because you know I
didn't want to go to Syracuse and not
just didn't wanna go kids but I didn't
want to go try to fill the shoes of
another guy felt like there was a lot of
pressure kind of coming and trying to
fill in for dining room that he was
running my role models just I didn't
want to build my legacy behind you know
somebody or someone to be wrong
you